shadow secretary of state for leveling
up lisa nandy your thoughts on that
first of all i mean i you know i think
what what is happening is extraordinary
it's not just that there are a lot of
families around the country this morning
who are looking at the
the revelations that have come to light
in this report and the prime minister's
response and thinking how can it
possibly be that we did follow these
rules when the prime minister was
telling us that they were important and
yet he presided over rot that ran right
the way through the heart of government
and refused to apologize refused to
acknowledge it refused to own up to it
until he was in serious trouble and
caught red-handed it's that we're now in
the extraordinary position of having a
prime minister who has lied he's lied to
the public has lied to the house of
commons you cannot trust the word that
he says so when he says i'll deal with
the cost of living crisis when he says
i'll stand up to russian aggression in
ukraine what do you do because you
cannot trust a word that this man says
400 people more than 400 people work in
downing street he can't possibly be
expected to know what they're all up to
he was there i mean he was there
he was there at a number of these events
there were emails in those um whatsapp
messages that are in that report and it
makes for really really uncomfortable
reading for anyone who's lived through
this and and remembers starkly how
difficult it was for most families in
this country where there were several
messages that were sent at the time that
shows that staff senior staff in downing
street knew what they were doing was
wrong and were trying to avoid being
caught there were messages going to
staff saying please leave by the back
door because there's too much
drunkenness going on in downing street
there were staff clubbing together to
buy fridges and suitcases of wine being
smuggled through the back door he has to
take he has to take some responsibility
for you actually
he might not have known you're saying
that he accept must accept
responsibility but he might not have
known what was going on it's not for me
to say whether he knew or not it's the
sue gray inquiry and the report makes
very clear that the prime minister came
to parliament he told us that there was
no party and then he turned out he was
actually at one of these parties it's
he's lied to the house of commons but
more importantly he's lied to the public
people put their trust in government to
an extraordinary degree during the
pandemic because we had to be in it
together in order to get through it my
inbox is absolutely full of people this
morning saying my dad died i didn't say
goodbye and i now feel why didn't i just
take the fine the prime minister's taken
no responsibility but i did people feel
like they did the wrong thing it's just
heartbreaking when you consider that
they were doing it because it was in the
interest of the country and he was
walking out of downing street while all
this was going on and standing in front
of the public and telling us this is
that this is the right thing to do they
may have looked at all of this and
they've only fined him once but but
they've they fined him for breaking his
own rules he said he would take
responsibility but he hasn't taken
responsibility he hasn't resigned he
only apologized when he was caught he's
not sorry that he did it he's sorry that
he got caught and what was striking
yesterday is that the debate that was
happening very publicly in the house of
commons amongst conservative mps and
ministers about what the prime minister
has done was very much about whether it
was in the interest of the conservative
party to junk him or not still the
country was completely cut out of this
conversation the debate wasn't have we
done the wrong thing is this in the
interest of the country that we have a
prime minister that cannot be trusted
the debate was are we going to win the
next election or not with this man in
charge yeah but he is bom he's as bomb
proof as the metal front door of downing
street at the moment because the back
benchers will not vote against him so
what is the point in having an
investigation into whether he misled
parliament because he would it would
have to be voted on in the chamber i
think it does matter with you've got a
prime minister who tells the truth or
not who has honesty integrity and
upholds proper standards in office i
think it matters to a lot of people in
this country but it doesn't just matter
because of partygate it matters because
trust is the glue that holds the whole
system together if you can't trust him
on this how on earth can you trust him
when he says he's going to help people
with soaring inflation rates when he
says that he's going to stand up to
russian aggression if you can't trust a
word that he says why would you trust
him on anything else well we can't trust
him because he says that there's going
to be well we hear there's going to be a
windfall tax later on we hear it and i
very much hope that it is true we
believe it's going to happen i mean i
strongly suspect there will be there
will be action today that it's been
briefed into the papers but also because
several times over the last few months
the prime minister has taken action when
he's been in real trouble in order to
distract from the troubles in government
we would very much welcome some action
on the cost of living but for months now
the chancellor has been telling us it's
not possible to have a windfall tax on
companies that made record profits
i think now it looks like it turns out
that it is possible to do that what we
want to see today is not just money
going to everybody 200 pounds of
people's energy bills to help people who
are struggling but money that is
targeted at those most in need the plan
that we've put forward would knock 600
pounds off energy bills for those most
struggling at the moment other than what
labour suggested i hope so i hope what
we'll see is a proper package of
measures today that actually get help to
people i don't know why they've dithered
and delayed for seven months i strongly
suspect they're acting now because i
think it's in their interests to deflect
from the sugree report but i'm very glad
to see it well i did put that to the
labor at the uh conservative minister
this morning and he said it was because
we were waiting for the off-gen report
they got that earlier on this week and
now they're they're working as quickly
as possible we are the only country the
only major economy in the world that has
put up taxes on working people a time of
crisis for most families and businesses
we've had 15 tax rises since boris
johnson took office we've been saying
for months now to this government you've
got to get help to people now we need a
proper package of measures today not
just a windfall tax on the big oil and
gas producers to not money off people's
energy bills but a long-term plan to
actually help to deal with what is now a
crisis for most families and businesses
across the country this week in the
house of commons the government had the
chance to act on that to take action to
invest in retrofitting homes that would
knock money off people's energy bills
not just this year but next year and
every year from now onwards and the
government decided not to do it we've
got this country has got to have a plan
in order to help people that every other
country in the world is doing this we
need a government that backs his people
and steps up to the scale of the crisis
but you you must at least give them some
sort of bouquet for coming up with the i
with the windfall taxes that's going to
go quite a long way to try to help
people in your constituency but i would
give them i would i would applaud them
if they backed down and said we were
wrong this is possible we can do this
and they backed our plans to do it
we've got to get money back into
people's pockets i've been challenged on
your show and many others over the last
few months about this whether it's
possible whether it's affordable whether
we can do it or not but every pound that
goes back into the pockets of working
people at the moment is a real godsend
for a lot of people in wigan in my
constituency and across the country this
is the difference between whether you
can get through the weekend or you know
feed your kids or whether you have bear
cupboards and you don't know what you're
going to tell your own family okay um
it's good to talk to you as always
thanks very much for joining us thank
you